[Music]
[Applause]
so glad to see so many people here so I
think we're gonna have a very
interesting and unusual discussion about
antimatter our first guest is an
assistant professor at MIT who focuses
not on answering big questions about the
universe by developing novel particle
detectors so please welcome Linda Lee
Winslow the next participant is an
assistant professor of physics at the
University of Massachusetts Amherst who
conducts research and experimental
nuclear and particle physics
please welcome Andre epic our final
guest this afternoon is also a physics
professor at MIT she's a member of the
IceCube experiment which is located at
the South Pole
please welcome Janet Conrad thanks so
much for being here talk to all of us
I guess Janet maybe you could get us
started by telling us how antimatter was
was discovered and what's so strange
about it
so antimatter was actually discovered in
the 1920s and it wasn't expected at all
at that point in time they had a pretty
nice description of how the world worked
they had you know certain building
blocks and there was no extra need for
any kind of an extra particle
particularly one that looks exactly like
the matter particle except that it has
opposite electric charge and so it was a
real shock when they actually saw this
they saw this in something which is
called a cloud chamber when a particle
goes through them coming from cosmic
rays you can actually see the particles
when the particles go through you can
put on a magnetic field and if you have
a particular kind of charge say a plus
charge it'll bend in one direction and
if you have a negative charge it'll bend
in the other direction and so that's
what they were seeing when they
discovered antimatter and it was not
expected at all
so they immediately did they immediately
know that there was this mystery of why
you know where is all the antimatter it
took a long time to actually understand
that every particle that we have in our
standard model and we have a lot of
particles in the standard model actually
have apparently an antimatter partner or
I I think if you think about the
standard model and all of the particles
in it at least we are certain that all
of the particles that have electric
charge have an antimatter partner
there is a special particle that is I'm
very very fond of called neutrinos it's
my favorite particle and neutrino is the
word neutrino means little neutral one
and it neutral is a good name for it it
has no electric charge associated with
it and so that's where the mystery of
whether neutrinos have a distinct
antimatter partner or not actually comes
from so we we know that something caused
this but could you talk about the
conditions that this mechanism has to
meet in order to favorite matter right
we have a very big problem and so if you
ask anybody what's their favorite
equation out there it's e equals MC
squared you can ask anybody what their
favourite equation that's the one that
they will come up with and y equals MC
squared tells you that energy can be
turned into particles it turns out there
they have to be turned into particles
and antiparticles in equal amounts so if
you think about it if I am producing
something that Sutton has electric
charge out of something that had no
electric charge I had better produced
the opposite charge also so that
everything will balance out so that
means that whenever we produce particles
out of energy we also get an equal
number of the antimatter with it and and
that's a big problem if you live in a
universe that is clearly only matter so
I like to say that the biggest crime
that ever happened is that somebody
stole all our it's completely gone and
that's a lot to steal and so so we have
to think about what it is that can
we make this happen and so we have to
introduce into our theory some kind of a
strange behavior among the particles
that is is that will give you a matter
antimatter imbalance so it tells you
that somehow the anti particles must be
behaving differently from the particle
from the particles and there are not so
many places within our standard model
where that can actually happen but it
turns out that neutrinos are one of the
places where you could actually fit that
in so maybe when Lindley could you tell
us about well I guess first about my
Arana particles which the neutrino might
be one so what are my Arana particles
and and what do they have to do with
this big question that we're trying to
answer so am i Arana particle is a
particle that's its own anti particle
and so you could figure out that there
might be some sort of mechanism where if
this is happening you could make more
matter than antimatter and so as janet
was sort of alluding to because
neutrinos don't have any electric charge
there's nothing really to tell you
whether they're their own anti particle
it's not obvious and as an
experimentalist it's the not obvious
thing that you want to go poke at so so
why is it that if you have a particle
that is both a matter and antimatter
particle it's the same thing then why
would that help with our problem where
we're actually trying to generate an
asymmetry so so if you have a particle
as its own anti particle article then
you couldn't make a process happen where
you make more matter than antimatter so
you don't conserve as Janet said the
matter and the matter in the reaction
make just a little bit more so you need
it with most of the particles most of
the cases of the particles in the
standard model you need a particle and
an antiparticle to collide and then that
produces energy or something like that
and the whole thing disappears but if
the neutrino is its own antiparticle
then effectively you can have an anti
neutrino and an anti neutrino
actually annihilate and disappear so you
can it's because there isn't any real
difference between an anti-neutrino and
a neutrino in this picture mm-hmm right
or another way of seeing it maybe is if
a neutrino comes in produced by some
process in its flight it transforms into
what we call anti neutrino and then
produces a reaction that produces the
matter of the other kind and so again
it's transformation that in that case
can occur at the very weird thing
neutrinos are being a little bit weird
and we still like to poke at them and
work actually what makes no tree no so
special I think that's why we love them
so much so so the person who first
proposed this idea that neutrinos might
be my Arana particles was in fact a Tory
my Raja who was a very strange character
could any of you tell us maybe Andre
could you tell us about him yeah he's a
fellow Italian so maybe I'm so he was
Sicilian and he was a genius since a
young age and he got into Fermi's group
in in Rome
right at the very early age of the
nuclear era when the nucleus was
starting to be understood and apparent
their stories that he showed up and in
in his group and the very first day he
was given the the the you know what was
the status of experiments were in in the
lab in Rome and mysteries of
calculations that couldn't be completed
they were difficult couldn't match up
what the the measurements were saying
and apparently he showed up the next day
with saying telling the people there
that they had done a good job because
everything that here they had calculated
so far was correct in only one night
apparently you know this mixture of
legend and reality but he was for the
few who actually knew him he was very
precocious
very independent he'd like to work alone
and the mystery is that he vanished
maybe this is a telltale all the things
he was studying no way it's a I'm
wondering what evidence we have that
thing sure is a Maya run a particle or
how we would find evidence that it is um
so obviously since we haven't answered
this yet it doesn't it's pretty hard to
answer this question so the idea that
that the field is really going after is
to look for this rare process called
neutrino less than beta decay and so the
mechanism is that the two electrons get
spit out with their two neutrinos and
you can either think of it as what Janet
said earlier that the two neutrinos
annihilate because they're my amount of
particles or that because they're my run
of particles they for they transform
into the other one it kind of gets
sucked back into the decay and so if we
saw this process of two electrons coming
out and no neutrinos then we've seen
evidence that the neutrinos a Meyer on a
particle and that would be really
exciting and there's arm ironic Reno's
wiggly line is they're coming out and
there we go and same ironic complete the
line there so you see there that now we
have two electrons coming out right and
we have lost the the anti neutrinos that
we're coming out with it the antimatter
is not coming out of that decay yeah
so this process made matter and no
antimatter and so that that is why we
are so excited about it
and so who figured this out it was
figured out at the 30s already the 30s
was a time when things moved extremely
quickly from figuring out what a beta
decay what is actually is to figuring
out well if that occurs then we'll we
will have the two electron decay as well
with neutrinos coming out but then if
neutrinos might have this property they
might as we say annihilate and and maybe
this other process exists it hasn't been
found yet so but just yeah make it very
clear the process on this side is has
been seen the process on this side is
the one that we are looking for as I
like
to see my neutrino this would be safe
this process over here only happens on
average once every 10 to the 21 years in
a typical nucleus but then this one how
rare is is is this one over here that's
at least 10,000 or 100,000 times slower
at least we only have limits on on its
occurrence and Lily's holding the record
on that limit Lindley's holding the
record currently at 10:26 but I I so
next week is the big meeting for all of
neutrino physics and I understand that
we're about to lose it to another the
third competitor between the one
experiment that's not represented on
this record or how do you end to the 26
years so what does that mean that that's
a record that is we haven't seen
anything and so we know it has to happen
less than one time in 10 of the 26 years
okay so to give you an idea for like how
rare this is the experiments that Andre
and I are building now we're going to
have one ton of nuclear material and we
expect 5 decays a year if it is at that
10 to the 26 year half-life okay so 5
and I realize that sounded a little
scary it's actually regular atoms that
we put together it's not nuclear
material sense of like a fuel from a
reactor or anything like that it's
special isotopically identify pure but
it's not dangerous and everybody uses a
different type of nuclear material right
like people have theories like oh this
one's gonna be better for this purpose
or yeah we argue about that a lot and we
argue how to use it - yes maybe the same
one but used a different way so what's
the materials so Andre and I both like
xenon I use it in a warm tank of liquid
and with this liquid mix light when
charged particles move through that's
how we will see those electrons and then
you detect that light with photo
detectors
and then you like to use your xenon cold
and liquid you know you know an attack
that's made cold and pure we don't mix
it with anything its refrigeration
really some like - 100 C or 170 Kelvin
roughly so it's it's not it's not really
the liquid nitrogen temperature but I
bet it makes great ice cream anyway yeah
yeah it's really cold as well right
right right
so then some days I like xenon in other
days I like to lure young and so my
other experiment is well the tag line
force the coldest cubic meter in the
known universe and we will give up the
known universe tag line if we discover
aliens doing don't pay the K research
with antimatter
with it I'll cold are we talking at 10
milli Kelvin so the universe at large is
around at 3 Kelvin so that's outer space
that's not very cold compared to us we
are a hundred thousand times smaller
temperature so this is the world's most
powerful it's called a dilution
refrigerator it's a it's a very
expensive version of the refrigerator
you have at home so there are 5 by 5 by
5 centimeter crystals of tellurium
dioxide so they are just a little bit
cloudy and they're mounted in copper and
the copper is connected to the
refrigerator and so the copper gets
cooled down and then it cools down all
of those crystals you see there so it's
19 towers 988 crystals so something that
you have to be very careful with when
you're building an experiment like this
is to have everything be very very very
clean because even the tiniest amount of
dirt actually has something in it that's
likely to have a radioactive decay and
then that will fool your experiment and
so it's a it's not only one of the
coldest places in the universe is one of
the cleanest places and when did we
first start looking for this decay and
and what were there's early attempts
like how did we get to the point we're
at now well I would say first you have
to discover neutrinos slide if you're
going to look for no neutrinos so I
think that the first thing you had to do
is discover the neutrinos which actually
we we did through looking for them
coming out of the beta decay process
that happens inside of reactors so the
first disguise
three of the of the family particles we
call neutrinos was actually an anti
neutrino and and that was discovered in
the 1950s how do we know it's an anti
neutrino if we think they might be the
same okay because when these particles
interact they are going to produce if it
is a anti particle coming in it's going
to produce a anti particle coming out
and so in comes my anti electron
neutrino and out comes a positron which
is the anti electron and so so you don't
actually know exactly what's coming in
you can't see it because you can't see
neutral particles in your detectors you
only see charged particles but out
suddenly out of nowhere pops this
positron and you say aha I must have had
an anti-electron neutrino coming in now
the thing is that that's how we've built
the theory we build the theory this way
because with all of the other charged
particles that we see it behaves this
way if you have a particle coming in you
have a particle coming out antiparticle
coming in antiparticle comes out of
these interactions but we don't know
that for sure but that was the the
assumption was that neutrinos and
antineutrinos are distinct and that they
create these their partner so we
actually can't tell in these
interactions and the only way I think
we'll be able to tell is through this
neutrino let's double beta decay instead
but we see many cases of both neutrinos
and antineutrinos now in fact the the
largest source of neutrino is coming at
you our neutrino is coming from the Sun
if you could see neutrinos you could
look at the Sun and this is what the Sun
would look like if you were looking at
it in neutrinos that's actually what the
Sun looks like in one of our very large
neutrino detectors called the super-k
detector but in fact you can see here
that these are pixels right you can see
each little square and the actual size
of the Sun is the size of the little
square that's in the middle so your
resolution your ability to actually
resolve something is very poor if you're
trying to see things in neutrinos
so it's not really a very
good sense to go ahead and develop if
you were evolving there isn't a lot of
need for it plus you also need to become
very very massive in order to be able to
see them there's like billions of them
going through each of us every ten
billions per square centimeter or the
size of a thumb okay
they just don't touch anything they
don't write they don't interact very
often they're very independent particle
so that we we called the weak
interaction because of the ones that are
in our standard model it is the least
likely to actually have an interaction
and so this makes them wonderful
particles to study because they can come
from a very long distance to you and
then if you get lucky they'll interact
in your detector but the interactions
are so rare that we have to build very
very large detectors so there needs to
be a very large detector to contain
their interactions where do you describe
it it's just it's such an amazing thing
that humans have built the ice cream
okay I love this experiment it's really
fun it's actually at the South Pole it's
right at the South Pole and we use the
Antarctic ice as the interaction
mechanism for the neutrinos so we're
looking for neutrinos that are produced
in the universe to come through and
interact in the ice and then we'll see
the particles that come out of those
interactions so to be able to see the
particles that are coming out we need
something that will detect what the
particles emit it turns out that they
will emit photons that the particles
that are coming out so we can use these
detectors which are called photo tubes
which are absolutely beautiful spiracle
objects that are a golden color the
golden metal is what's responding to the
the light and so we needed to drill a
hole because we want to put this deep
below the Antarctic ice about a
kilometer down and so how do you drill a
hole in ice no hot water
that's exactly right we just take hot
water and we melt our way all the way
down in the hole we put in the detector
and we allow it to refreeze around the
detector and it is literally a kilometer
cubed in size
so there's one of these in many place so
there's yeah there's about 5,000 of
these light collection modules over this
column they form this kind of cubic
array mm-hmm and we look for neutrinos
to come in from outer space and interact
in this and produce a big burst of light
which we read out and from that we can
understand all kinds of interesting
information about them but the one thing
that we can't tell is if they're a
neutrino or an anti neutrino we can tell
you what kind of neutrino they are
neutrinos come in three different types
within our standard model and we define
what the type of neutrino is based on
what it produces in the interaction so
we can tell you if a neutrino came in
and produced an electron we can tell you
if it comes in and produces a muon or
we're looking for the case where a
neutrino comes in and it produces a Tau
but we cannot tell you if that was a
Anti electron neutrino or because we
don't have a magnetic field so we would
be very very hard to build a magnet that
could cover a kilometer cubed yeah we
have other uses for that magnet right
but what's what's neat though is that
you can get the handle of it's like how
important neutrinos are because they run
the gamut from these very very
high-energy neutrinos that are more
energetic than anything we've ever been
able to make on earth down to the
thermal neutrinos that were made in the
Big Bang and therefore if you'd like
tweak the properties of neutrino just a
little bit and the biggest one is this
Meyer on a neutrino anti neutrino
difference you can really change how the
universe formed and I think that's
really what drives all of us here on
stages that's why we love this particle
yeah it's not on hell and there might be
other besides just the my Arana question
there could be also other neutrinos so
we all right that's a great question
about neutrinos is that it's the one
part of the standard model where we've
really seen deviations from what we
actually expected from what the
theorists were telling us we ought to
see and it is it is a place where nature
is really talking to us instead of us
may be telling nature what to do with
our theories right and I really like
exploring there and we have seen
hence out of nature that there might be
additional neutrinos beyond the three
that we know of and love so well but
it's very complicated the picture of
what we're seeing in all of our
experiments and so we've been working
slowly toward definitive evidence that
something is really going on and one of
my experiments Mini Boone just took a
really big leap this week we just put
out a new paper that moved us closer but
Natalie they asked me do I see this as
my Eureka moment and the answer is not
quite yet you know it takes scientists a
long time to decide this is really
something completely different
basically you saw evidence that maybe
there's a sterile neutrino right which
is right some so if neutrinos are like
ghostly particles people often describe
them as just with that nickname sterile
neutrino is a shadow of right absolutely
ghost is a great description for
neutrinos because how do you know you
have a ghost in your house you know
because you look around and there's this
debris
you know the ghost came in and made a
mess the same thing happens in our
detector the neutrino comes in and it
makes a mess we don't see the neutrino
come in itself but we see the mess that
it makes so I think ghost is a really
good description of it but the sterile
neutrino actually will interact even
less often than the standard model
neutrinos that we have and so so what
happens with them is we have to see them
when they play a game with the other
neutrinos of neutrino oscillations
causing those neutrinos to disappear and
come back again and so so that's where
the sterile neutrino comes in but all of
this tells you how rich the field of
neutrino physics is that we have all of
these different clues like they might be
Maya Rana coming from theory or they
there might be sterile neutrino is
coming from experiment and so there's a
really rich place to work and we
actually think that if you put these
ideas together you might be able to get
an over
all theory that can explain all of these
different aspects yeah that's something
that has always struck me is that we
kind of look to neutrinos to solve many
of the mysteries that we have questions
about for being a particle that you are
not all that aware of probably they're
they're actually a pretty important
particle in your life because for
example the Sun wouldn't shine if we
didn't have neutrinos the very first
process that ignites the Sun is actually
one that involves neutrinos in it so but
more importantly neutrinos are what blew
up
stars and supernovae and make all the
elements I want to send a light not
black the neutrinos from the Sun yeah
this particular process in fact was
actually published in 2014
Forex e noise the name of the experiment
at the same lab where quarry is in
central Italy and it's a big sphere of
an organic liquid that has a property of
producing some light when interactions
happen in it like a neutrino comes in
and hits an electron for example that's
how we we detect these neutrinos from
the Sun and it's arguably the large the
one largest rate radio cleanest volume
in the universe so this experiment was
able to measure the neutrinos from the
Sun at low energy for the first time on
a event by event and and that allowed us
to identify that these belong to this
process as opposed to another process in
the Sun and it's a whole chain of
processes that emit them the sun is
shining right it takes a really long
time for the photons that are produced
in the center of the Sun to make their
way out go down lower in energy and
lower in energy till they're visible and
then they finally come to us eight
minutes across to come to us but it
takes you know ten thousand years ten
and a hundred thousand depending on who
you talk to
right so you never know maybe the Sun
turned off we will know only in a
hundred thousand years yeah I think
we're fine
but you can tell us that it didn't it's
fine right
yeah the neutrinos are there right so we
know that we're safe for another 100,000
yeah beyond that yeah I guess getting
back a little bit to these experiments
that are directly looking for neutrinos
double beta decay I'm still a bit
curious how we figure it out even how to
do an experiment like this I mean what
material you know you said you prefer
xenon how do we figure out like okay if
we get a bunch of xenon together maybe
we can see this and yeah
well I was telling you a little bit
about the the type of nuclei that can do
this process and so you can actually
then go through we have tables of
isotopes for a variety of reasons and
you could pick out and there's about 50
candidate isotopes and yeah and then in
order to detect something the higher
energy it is the easier it is
and so if we've sort of taken like the
ten highest energy was and those are the
ones that that are easy to would be easy
to see and then you try to figure out
how to build a detector with them and
that's really actually all three of us
on stage are experimental physicists our
job is to build detectors and answer
questions and and that's why actually
this field for for me is so fun is that
it's like this game of okay I have xenon
what can I do is xenon and you know it's
fun because you can actually do actually
every technique was xenon I think one of
the interesting things about it though
is that the ideas behind how to do this
how to look for neutrinos double beta
decay
we're actually identified by one of the
really great female physicists Maria
gabbert Meir I have an award for her and
she's just Ana was an amazing person I
know she's she's yeah great girl maybe
you want to tell a little bit about her
um so right so it's under your saying
sort of the 30s was sort of this this
time of great jump for with our
understanding of nuclear physics and she
had a preliminary model for how the
nucleus work as she did the first
calculations of this rate doesn't give
us the goalposts and if you ask sort of
why it took so long well first we didn't
know if neutrinos really existed we had
to measure
in the fifties and then we had this sort
of detour where we didn't we wanted to
see the sunshine and so in the 60s we
started to try to look for these solar
neutrinos and that that turned into a
debacle that took 30 years 40 years all
that great 40 years I would say I mean
it was a great piece for our jobs I did
but but that that simple question of
well we'll just detect the neutrinos
from the Sun turned out to be really
hard and that's easily compared and yet
and that's easy compared to double beta
decay and so that's where we are now is
now it's okay now we know kind of what
to do can we can we do it yeah and and
we've been doing it not we I mean as a
community we've been doing it for about
half a century almost now I think the
first experiments were in the either
late 60s or early 70s with detectors of
the size of a gram or so and then now
we're thinking about tons so I guess
there was a range of that Meir
calculated like it could be this likely
or it could be this likely yeah well
actually there's a there's a history to
that too originally the first
calculation seemed to say that the
neutrino less decay should have been
faster than the regular to neutrino
decay and then relooking at those
calculations it turned out not to be so
but there was uncertainty and to have to
calculate these things because it's new
physics and so anytime there's a new
process you know you put in numbers
which are reasonable or minimal
extensions of what you know but you
fundamentally don't know so you have to
at some point look at that and then you
do the biggest most sensitive experiment
you can do in a reasonable timeframe you
know a few years or something and you
look for the process and if the
experiment is too small it won't see it
and then you you you go to the next
stage because you've learned something
you don't have to do it better and and
that's how the field has progressed so
there's so there is some range and we've
kind of cut through part of the range
we've excluded some range and now we
know that it this process is rarer than
a certain length of you know length of
time is that kind of how it works I yes
so how how far are we along the scale so
I would say we've just reached a very
exciting point because because of this
information coming from sort of other
types of experiments we now kind of know
where the goal posts are and so so the
best limits now are 10 to the 26 years
the next set of experiments is a me for
ten to the twenty seven years and then
if we can build an experiment that's
sensitive about to ten to the twenty
eight years and we don't see something
then we know that the neutrinos are not
my Arana particles because there's just
not any not much theoretical space left
for them to be and so we're really 100
times better we I'd do a hundred times
better and so so that's really kind of a
neat place to be of course if Janet
sterile neutrinos exist we could have
even more fun in that for us like it
moves things around us to where this
decay would where we're looking in that
it would be much more fun it was the
copis you talk about our based on this
minimal diagram that yeah that has been
shown which is you know a very
reasonable place to go but on the other
hand neutrinos have surprised us and so
we might actually see the double beta
decay with that with a half-life that
doesn't quite match this expectation
because the process might actually be
more complicated than what was shown on
the screen
we're talking about a fundamental
process of nature if it if it exists and
maybe nature is more complicated than
the minimal complication what we're
trying to add to its many things so what
would it be like if you did discover
discover this how would it all play out
champagne
well I I I actually I wrote a story
about one of these experiments a few
years ago that had finished Gerda
yeah and they talked about how they
blinded the data and then they had an
unblinding so maybe I mean I don't know
if people are aware that that's how it's
done but physicists are so careful that
you don't even know that you're gonna
make or you're not biased while you're
doing the analysis right you just do it
without even looking at the the numbers
and then everyone gets together and then
unbinds it is that how it happens yeah I
guess in most cases that's how it
happens
it's a little experiment specific
exactly how that is done but yeah and
the pressure is very high on this
measurement in particular now there's a
lot of competition a lot of people
trying to do it and any claim in fact
there has there had been in the past a
positive claim of having found this this
decay that turned out to be wrong and so
even more so I think there's the burden
of proof on us well if we think it was
the
Gurda predecessor but it was it was a
much smaller collaboration kind of using
this similar technique but I think it
shows you can go wrong and because this
discussion shows you can go wrong in
both ways so for example you know
there's an experiments that set limits
on the two neutrino double beta decay
that we're just not correct and and it's
very important to go and explore even
those regions that are ruled out because
it turned out that you know they had
made a mistake and miss the signal
that's a really crummy thing to happen
and it can go the other way also you can
have some kind of an effect in your
experiment that is looking a lot like
the signal and it's really important for
somebody else to come along and do a
different experiment in order to make
sure that what you were seeing really is
the signal so I think this goes to sort
of why I work on two different
experiments and why on the stage you see
three different experiments is that in
order to really know that we saw the
signal we probably want to see it in two
different isotopes so I to Laurium and
xenon we can share that and and two
different detector techniques because it
could be a detector artifact and there
that has happened in the past that we've
detected things that turned out to be
something we didn't understand about the
detector they're only talking about five
events you know if they get lucky and so
it's a very tiny number of events and so
you know it could be that something's
gone wrong people are a little bit hard
on scientists in the sense that when
something when they see something that
looks like a signal scientists can say
oh well we have observed this to a
certain level and people are like have
you discovered something or not
and it's it's really hard for us to say
yes for a very long time until there's
many many cross checks on these things
because it's so easy to go wrong
experimental physics is a real art so
when if for when you discover this how
big of a deal would it be I mean what
you know is this this is the last great
question of the standard I think it's
really huge because right now we have no
idea what the larger theory is we have
reason to think that there is a larger
theory because we can put together this
thing called the standard model that has
many particles in it and we can start
arranging them just the same way as you
would arrange a periodic table and you
know we have a lot of history with
putting together tables of things and
then discovering that there was an
underlying theory behind it
plus there's stuff that we don't
understand like dark matter right we
have no idea what the larger theory is
for many many years we pursued
supersymmetry and that just has not
turned out to be the right direction
even though it was theoretically very
very promising so we need something that
will direct us toward what what kind of
larger theory there is a neutralist
double beta decay connects to a very
specific class of theories and would
allow us to take all those ideas that
are out there and really narrow them
down
mm-hm yeah so maybe some I know you're
all three experimentalist and there's a
kind of wall between you and your
theorists colleagues but maybe you could
talk about just if this decay is
observed what larger theories that might
point to you know it would mean that we
would have this mechanism for
understanding yeah so so what is there a
name for it you know it's not string
theory or yeah I guess let me just make
a little intro to this if neutrinos
behave like this in this funny way of
being their own antiparticles in a way
that naturally opens the doors to these
objects to exist I mean there
might be particles out there that also
have this feature no charge and behave
but which are heavy enough that have
never been seen and in fact I would say
that a majority of theorists now that
doesn't mean that it's a right way to
look sometimes as doesn't necessarily
mean that it's more probable necessary
but being the good example is you being
a good example of that but there's a lot
of thinking about whether the dark
matter for example is made of particles
which are also of this kind and are may
be linked to processes and physics which
are mediated by particles which are too
heavy for the LHC for example I have
discovered and and the other thing is
you know our current theory lacks to
tell us why these neutrinos don't don't
exist I mean II suppose they don't exist
and neutrinos are just the standard ones
that we that we know a good theory to me
is a theory that explains predicts but
also tells us whether any of the
possible solutions that doesn't violate
any fundamental postulate of a theory
isn't seen and neutrinos based on on
what we we know should actually behave
fit this way because you can write terms
in the theory that behave exactly like a
neutrino that you know turns into ice
anti particle without really violating
any of the fundamental pillars of the
theory and so a theory that has
solutions that you kind of say oh I just
throw these out because they're
unimportant is still an incomplete
theory to me we've we've made a lot of
progress by arguing if it can happen it
will happen and you know we have
something has to stop things from
happening
for it for us to not see it and and so
that's sort of what's what's behind that
particular idea but one of the things
that we think is that at very high
energy scales there is
a grand unified theory a theory that
that is very simple and then as you go
to lower and lower energies becomes more
and more complicated
so whatever existed right after the Big
Bang with the theory is very simple and
then as the universe cooled and energies
decreased symmetries broken things got
and things became very complicated so if
people like to describe it as as you
make a pot of soup and it's all very
homogenous when you let it cool and get
globs of stuff and and kind of that's
what's happened we believe with our
particles and so there are these grand
unified theories that have these my
errata heavy partners in them and to try
to probe at those we need to look for
the light mire on of particles it's also
very hard to get rid of them to write a
theory that doesn't have these pulp out
in many ways I mean so in that sense
it's very compelling and the neutrino is
the only particle that we know exists
that we can directly probe and so it's
unnatural places this is always a
problem for for theorists because
there's a whole set of things out there
that it's very hard to get rid of in
your theory one of them is is these my
Arana particles sterile neutrinos are an
example of this extra neutrino that I'm
looking for proton decay is another big
one the fact that we haven't seen
protons decay which is quite good for us
because we add if our protons were
decaying but many many theories have
died on the point that they are
predicting proton decay and it hasn't
happened so so yeah so we're really at a
point where I think we also need to
start thinking a little bit more about
the way we approach our theories and
whether this if it can happen it will
happen is the right way to think about
it
I think that at this point particle
physics is really at a turning point and
I think it's a turning point that's
gonna be really driven by experiment so
sometimes Theory drives experiment and
sometimes experiment drives theory and
the most the healthiest view of the
field is when it's going back and forth
rotating back and forth and I think
we're seeing a rotate
right now so to that point of just that
even though it can happen this you know
the particle going neutrino list decay
it actually might not happen so could
either of you who were actually
searching with this decay could you talk
about what it would mean if if this
decay doesn't exist and the the neutrino
is not its own anti particle and that's
called a Dirac you know right as opposed
to Meyer on a neutrino so yeah well in
that case the neutrino is just like all
the other particles of the standard
model which would be disappointing for
us but we still answered a really
important question and then going back
to what Janet says is working on this
this this theory where if it can happen
it does then we'd have to find a reason
why why it's not happening and so that
would be then pushing back on our theory
friends okay explain to us then what
exactly is preventing this from being
there so if a neutrino and antineutrino
are different particles then but I don't
have charge so it seems like they should
be the same one so maybe they have some
other property that there's some other
property we know particles carry these
sort of intrinsic properties charge is
the easiest one to discuss right they're
sort of like you know it's sort of like
the DNA of the particle and charge is
one little bit of its DNA and it can
have lots of other aspects of its DNA
also so then neutrinos would have to
have like an extra little chromosome
that's preventing them from being my
Arana and I'd have to explain but it is
there we don't know why and we have no
explanation for that and you know
experiment police are also looking for
any magnetic tiny B behavior of the
neutrino so far there's only limits we
haven't found any but that would be
again it found that would be a strong
indication of the rock behavior because
now you have electromagnetic properties
of this neutrinos so it's not completely
charged less in the sense of that we
think it is so far that'll be a really
hard experiment to do yeah
so that's the thing though about
experiment if you do the easy
experiments first and then what's what's
laughing it gets harder and harder
harder a hunter or brand new brand new
like you then have no idea what's good
but it's only by trying yeah that you'll
hit the brand new I mean it it's not by
being idle and not doing anything that
you'll you'll you'll hit something the
brand new is an important point though
right now at least in my area of
neutrino physics one of the things that
worries me is I see people proposing
larger and larger versions of the
detectors that we've worked on for many
many years and you know I worry that at
some point it's just not going to be
sustainable to build these detectors
bigger and bigger that we have to
actually completely rethink our
technology and our approaches and and we
really need to put some investment into
that well I guess accelerator science
has also going being been going that
route bigger and bigger accelerators
higher and higher energies but more and
more the low energy effects of physics
that high energy is being pursued also
because practically building bigger
machines gets harder I'm actually
working on something related to that I'm
actually working on how to take tiny
accelerators which are called cyclotrons
make them even more powerful than they
have been in the past and then you can
bring the accelerator to the experiment
instead of having to build the
experiment next to the accelerator and
so you can take these existing very
large detectors and put an accelerator
next to them and the nice thing about
this is that actually this particular
accelerator that I'm working on will
also be I think a really valuable source
for medical isotopes to at the same time
so so you can feel like you can do more
than just the basic science with it yeah
and so I was thinking about this earlier
actually when you talk about that right
now the limit is on 10 to the 26 years
that this what is that by the way that's
like trillion trillion 100 trillion
trillion years I I would but then now
you're trying to look to see if it
decays in a thousand trillion trillion
so you need ten times more material to
do that and then to go one more order of
magnitude you need 100 times more
material where you're studying
monitoring it for the same amount of
time hoping that one particle in there
will undergo this decay so is it
possible to get 100 tonnes of xenon I
mean aren't we already kind of at the
limit of what we can do possible it's
very possible certainly technology
doesn't scale that easily and and and
when you scale up an experiment there is
a phase where you gain quickly but then
there's a sink a second phase where the
complexity of the scale-up itself the
engineering complexity of the scale-up
cake kicks back and and so it's unclear
whether as Janet said you can just brute
force scale-up only I think you have to
get smarter as well and so mitigate the
scale up with with smart tools are smart
techniques that you can implement and I
think I think we're all trying to think
about these possibilities and there are
some ideas there that are being
developed still in the in the proto
phase CSO sort of building on that so
you guys saw that pretty picture of core
a with all those crystals the next thing
we need to do with core is actually were
gonna take crystals that not only are
cold but they also give off light and so
that's actually what that red crystal
was about because it glows if a charged
particle goes through in addition to
just heating up and so that's sort of
the things that we're looking at is how
to be smarter about the detectors that
we're already building so are these
experiments running right now both of
your experiments yeah I mean as far as
I'm concerned
XO 200 is running in in a salt mine in
New Mexico why are they always in
[Laughter]
because we don't like easy things no the
reason is how our experiments all have
to run on the ground to shield them from
cosmic rays in the atmosphere and so we
use the earth as a shield and we have to
go
you know roughly a kilometer or so on
the ground and 4x200 at that time in the
United States that wasn't a very
available hole in the ground that we
could go to it's in this particular case
unlike the core example this is not a
laboratory this is a salt mine where
they dispose nuclear contaminated
materials from the laboratories I have
enriched for the bombs
which sounds like a really bad plan for
an experiment that needs to be very does
but the mine is very large and it's kind
of a proof that it's actually done
fairly well yeah in a way because we
could run one of the cleanest
experiments and in the world a kilometer
away from a storage of barrels of
plutonium contaminated stuff we're
underground but the actual detector
itself is is a xenon liquid container
like a bucket inside a cryostat which is
an instrument that makes it cold and
then it has layers of shielding from
radiation that comes from the from the
periphery of the detector it's been
running since 20 the late 2010 I would
say we've already published data three
times it's scheduled to end in 2018 and
we're already into the the design phase
of the of the of a five-ton follow-up
which is still on paper or silicon
called nxo and and that's going to be a
scale-up of what we've learned with x200
with a number of we think clever
additions or changes that make the
scale-up better but there's going to be
as far as XO is concerned the XO program
a gap of of taking data for for a while
our our technology and it's the strength
and the risk of the technology is that
it goes in in steps there's one detector
you build one detector you run it and
then if want a bigger one you have to
build a bigger detector core for example
is made of crystals and so there's
technologies like that that could be
scaled up more in phases in principle
maybe not for itself specific
but others and that really depends on
the choice of the technology in a way
going for the big job well this is a
container of the extra 200 experiment
it's made of copper this is commercial
copper but it's commercially selected
copper every screw that went into this
detector that now is in the picture is
empty but it's uh it's instrumented
inside and then filled with the liquid
has been screened for radioactivity so
we have to go an excruciating programme
of monitoring and a saying every
material every component every cable
every screw that goes in there because
one hotspot one screw that wasn't
cleaned appropriately there's a
fingerprint on it will swamp the rate of
the detector completely and so that's a
big risk obviously you know and
sometimes you know only when you put it
together and run it and opening it up to
fix it is months of work that you don't
want to do so X 200 was put on the
ground it was actually welded in this
container never to be opened again
thankfully but it was designed to be
possibly opened if needed and it was in
that sense built very much like a
satellite is built you test it and then
you seal it and you just hope it runs
you hope you're pretty confident it does
but you know you're never really sure is
the turning on of the detector was an
interesting phase so next is gonna come
next hopefully I mean it's gonna be a
much more expensive experiment it's a
bigger collaboration we've expanded the
collaboration as well and then on the
side we're thinking also about what
after next so in terms of being more
clever and some of our collaborators are
developing brand new techniques to
identify the appearance of barium atoms
in eggs enon five ton container that
would be the tell-tale sign that a
double beta decay has occurred and so
they're developing imaging techniques to
measure not just a single atom in a
matrix but that one that corresponds to
a certain amount of release of energy in
the detector and so on and so forth
that's kind of beyond the next soar
project
but it's possibly ways of being smarter
so before we go to questions from the
audience I just wanted to ask each of
you just to make a prediction I guess of
when you think this decay is going to be
seen first of all if you think it's
going to be seen and then kind of what
your hunches about the prospects you
know I have a mild optimism they will it
will be seen yeah I have to be careful
you know it goes back to blinding you
you look for something because you you
really think it could be there and
that's for sure
you have to stay honest with the other
answer being possible as well otherwise
I think that goes down a bad spiral in
general whether you know when you know
if yes then when it's beyond me but I
hope in my lifetime I really can make a
prediction on that so I think I'm going
to make a hard prediction I think we're
gonna see it in in the at the end of the
next generation of experiments so 10
years and it's going to be in a part of
the parameter space that no one was
expecting to see it you just don't mind
oh I did yeah the answer to I don't you
have the sterile neutrinos and I'm gonna
say that it's some combination of
sterile neutrinos and a weird mechanism
okay okay now you can go yeah I have the
same for you one of the things that
happens is that you you do these blank
analyses and you open the box and you
expect one thing say nothing or a signal
a specific kind of signal you open the
box and you discover it's not what you
expected at all and I think that's
what's gonna happen to them and and I
think that that will be really fantastic
for particle physics and I also was
going to guess 10 years and that will
guarantee a lot of jobs do a lot of fun
okay well I'm sure everybody has some
questions they've been racking up trying
to understand this but is there any
evidence of the annihilation of the
majority of matter
you know like Penzias and Wilson
they measured the cosmic background
radiation for the Big Bang is that
related to the annihilation of matter
and antimatter are how do is there any
empirical or real evidence of that the
current the when everything annihilated
except all the matter that's left yeah
do be happy that I'm afraid that that
happens so early in our history of our
universe that we can actually can't look
back to that but I think one of the
things that is really interesting about
neutrinos is that they actually allow
you to look further back in the history
of the universe than we can with the
photons so you know what happens is that
you have a universe that's just full of
energy photons and they're they're just
sort of swimming around and then finally
the universe gets to be big enough where
the photons get for enough away from
each other that they're not interacting
and then they they sort of freestream
outwards and that's the point that's the
last you can look back to that point and
you can't look any further into what
happened in the early universe for these
fingerprints neutrinos that happens with
very very early in the universe and so
we could see the cosmological neutrinos
we could learn an enormous amount the
problem is those neutrinos really don't
have very much energy they're all
hanging around right now you know
there's about a what is it a billion of
them in every cubic meter of space but
they're not doing very much because
they're not very energetic and so trying
to figure out how to find them that's
that is one of the Holy Grails of
neutrino physics and there's some ideas
out there but it's that's yeah if you
thought double beta decay was hard try
to deny that but it's a good question
and if we could get there we would get
there we would go yeah let's thank our
speakers
you
[Music]